there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock all right you guys it's
Tuesday once again and here we are with
episode 121 I think yeah it's gonna be a
good one well yeah because like I said
we like to do a paranormal and then sure
crime and then paranormal again and we
hadn't done a paranormal one in a long
time and we also hadn't done one of our
infamous recaps are the infamous are
they just for haunting episode yeah
it could be either like yeah the
interesting thing about this one and I'm
actually surprised we haven't got around
to this because we have actually talked
about this case a little bit before we
talked about it on our show about the
Warrens because this was something where
the Warrens was involved I don't really
remember if we went a lot into it
because we covered like a lot of cases
on that one so we kind of wanted to go a
little more in-depth with this one
because there's actually like a whole
bunch of extraneous stuff that they left
out of the haunting episode and also
there was a cop there was a homicide
involved with this case yeah I tried to
use it as a defense in his manslaughter
trial his murder it was supposed to be a
murder trial looking for a trial but he
got found guilty of manslaughter he
didn't get much time spoiler alert for
them but also I found out too when I was
researching this case and I can't
believe I didn't know this because
actually I put this case in my book the
unseen hands like a little summary of it
there was in 1983 a made-for-tv movie
about this case and about the trial in
particular and it kind of went into the
same kind of stuff and it's like we
found it on YouTube it was made for NBC
when Kevin Bacon isn't it Andy Griffith
was in it Cloris Leachman was in it it
was disaster it was terrible and
wonderful and I'm so happy that it
exists I forgot how bad made-for-tv
movies were
and a lot of them there were some good
ones in the 71 yeah but yeah this one
was look like I made my community
community television theater I mean if
you ever wanted to see Kevin Bacon cuz
it came out I think the year before
Footloose so if you ever want to see
like Kevin Bacon with his patented
sticky-outy Footloose hair like acting
like he's possessed by demons then this
is the movie for you
yes he's like growling and crawling and
it's fantastic and there's a lot of
differences between the case as
presented in that movie in that
made-for-tv movie as it is in the
haunting a lot of different like I said
a haunting left a significant chunk of
that out yeah but you know we I can see
why they did it but TV just probably
didn't ballast it alive but we'll get to
that yeah this should be this should be
a fun show yeah yeah you got an
announcement to make about the audiobook
today yeah I finished anything the
audiobook and I loaded it yeah so now it
has to go through the quality control
and if it passes all the ACX quality
control which is shattered because I
already I had the little app that you
know makes sure that it's you know you
know unless something drastic happened I
don't know but so it should be I think
about 10 days and then it should go up
on sale but obviously I'll announce it I
made a little commercial for it and
everything so that also subsequent
episodes it'll start showing up on there
it's a little commercial so listening to
it it sounds like the best recording so
far well yeah it better not better since
we got this nice new yeah you know how
did have a little waveform looked at
passed it passed everything right past
all these yeah like I said because I
don't know if you know I probably said
this before but the audio book ACX you
know to do the audio audible yeah for
audiobooks were audible they have very
very specific parameters that you have
to adhere to and so sometimes it's like
I you know I don't know it's hard for me
to say because I hear it on different
speakers and it's like it sounds better
on some speakers and you know we're
doing some speakers but as long as it's
within those parameters to beginning I
thought it sounded good on headphones
and it sounded actually pretty good
coming out of my little shitty Mac
speakers so that's probably a good sign
it's not it sounded like the best one so
far I thought well yeah that's what I
thought too I mean like I said it should
because this is a much more expensive
evidently they got more stringent with
the the Quality Control so yeah but this
the program said it passed so yeah so it
should be good problem like I said so as
soon as it finishes going through that
it should be up for sale ended up being
17 hours long so whatever they want to
charge you for that audiobook you're
gonna get your money's worth that's a
lot of listening time cuz I don't have
any control over audible prices they
they have like a little algorithm that
goes by how long it is and that's how
audio books kick ass though they sell
Forbes says that you know sales in them
is going up a lot past couple bucks this
year of it was like one of the strongest
years for record for audiobook sales on
record and they got a good profit margin
we usually make about 10 bucks on one
huh yeah it they actually have a really
nice set up there was a creator getting
a lot I mean obviously if someone else
recorded it other than me I would have
to like split it with the narrator but
since I do it myself I get all of its
okay but yeah so as soon as that gets
going you know I'm trying to finish up a
couple other projects and then I'm gonna
start recording my fiction also because
that's actually never been an audio book
format and I'd like to offer that so I'm
gonna relaunch all my fiction with new
covers and yeah sweet collections that
you guys gonna love that I think yeah
and that'll sell so that'll be my next
project and then I'll have to start
working on faceless ville and volume 3
also amid all of that but you know we'll
see how it goes it'll next year or two
should be very exciting a lot of new
stuff coming out let's see second
editions to some of the other audiobooks
that are already out there yeah I'm
probably gonna rerecord probably
rerecord unseen hand yeah part one of
phases Pavillon probably rerecord that
yeah Mammoth Mountain yeah there's the
Steve Mara books yeah I'll get around
yeah we'll get around to it yeah I got a
build a studio yeah we're working on it
yeah we got sound proofing stuff border
yeah common
new stuff so we'll see how that goes
let's see what else new announcements
let's see one of our patreon supporters
Justin actually increased his support
this past week so that was awesome thank
you very much Justin thanks Justin and
also like I said I'll say at the end
like if you want to financially support
the show I don't need to say it twice
you guys know also if you want to check
out our last movie review it was a
double feature we did dead and buried
and death line aka raw meat both
directed by Gary Sherman one from 1973
one from 1981 kind of underrated horror
flicks so go check that out if you
haven't already and also we did our
matinee show which came out a couple
days ago on Sunday and that was like
what did what even movies did we see
[Laughter]
I liked boy erased we're running out of
movies do it the other ones were kind of
underwhelming family yeah there's nobody
really nothing good started this week
like I think only one movie started and
it's not even playing here I have to
lower ourselves to see a star is born
yeah we're gonna have to end up seeing
that we've been trying to avoid it it's
gotten good reviews though it's like it
might be alright I've seen some other
versions of it and you know they were
okay it's not really my kind of movie
but you know that's what we signed on
for when we decided to do the matinee
show I'm like sometimes we're gonna have
to see some movies we've really watch
these things so you don't have to yeah
so we really wouldn't and sometimes like
I said what especially when we go see
the animated ones you're always like
kvetching about how you don't want to go
see it and it's crazy but then it's like
he ends up really liking them like he
didn't want to see the Grinch cuz he's
like oh man that's gonna suck so bad
Vegas then he ended up breaking her nose
pretty good so you know and small foot
was cute too i really small foot I like
the little the little yetis alright so
let's get to talking about but first
let's talk about the episode of a
haunting that is about this particular
case the Glassell family you know the
glassful family and also Arnie Cheyenne
Johnson who married into the Glassell
family later on the episode of a
haunting is actually from season two I
think is episode 4 and it's called weird
demon
we're team as well yeah this is the one
man I remember this one it was creepy
when I first saw it you had that little
kid going he's coming after me you know
that man he pushed me remember that trip
yeah so basically what happened this
actually took place in 1980 in
Connecticut you got Debbie Glassell who
I think at the time was 25 26 years old
and her boyfriend Arnie Johnson who I
think was about 18 or 19 and they had
rented this house and they were going to
now I don't think Debbie's little
brother whose name was David he was
about 11 at the time and I don't think
he was going to be living with them but
I think that he came with them to like
help clean up the rental house and I
think that Arnie's mom was gonna stay
with them too
I think that was how the set up was
gonna go yeah and they got so spooked
over the place that they decided to lead
it to split and they left her there on
her own yeah so basically in the
haunting episode and I'm not sure um you
know cuz I've read different accounts of
this case from other places and I don't
think it was as immediate as it appeared
on the haunting episode because pretty
much they go to clean up the rental
house and they bring the little kid
David with them and David goes to like
sweep out one of the bedrooms or
something like that chime asleep out the
bedroom and he goes in there and then he
says oh you know we have a problem like
the landlord or whoever lived here
before like left their bed which to me I
was like why is that a problem I'm like
a free bed I mean you probably want to
burn the mattress just in case because
you don't know what happened on it but
you don't ya don't take mattresses off
curves you guys cuz you'll get like
cooties but that's what happened in New
York that's people like garbage picking
but yeah so then so they're just like oh
whatever we'll just call the landlord
and have him get rid of it cuz you know
they didn't want a free bed I guess so
then the kid goes back in the bedroom
and immediately comes like running out
and he's like push pushed me yeah he
pushed me and he said that it was like
an old man he kind of described it
because the description of it
of different on the show than it was
like in real in real life you know what
I mean I think all he said he called it
an old man and I don't even remember if
he said on a haunting but that he had
like a checkered shirt or a plaid shirt
or something like that yeah well they
give to he gave to different
descriptions yeah on the haunting he
just says it was an old man and I just
made for television series and then made
for television movie he said that it was
a little man about four feet - yeah a
little man with a plaid shirt on yeah
but he had been burnt yeah he said it
looked like I was like like Freddy
Krueger yeah you've been been burnt and
that he had little hubs on his feet like
the devil yeah some accounts I said said
that they thought he did have horns
although like I said I think that what
they saw at the beginning was different
from what they saw later on because
later on they started referring to it
not as the old man but as the Beast and
I think they went into that on a
haunting - yeah so like I said on a
haunting it seemed like immediately kid
goes in the house to help them clean up
says there's some old manis in the room
he pushed me and then you know Debbie
and Arnie go in there and obviously
there's no one in there so but David
just runs outside he's like you know
[ __ ] that I'm just I'm sitting out so he
just sits out by the tree and so his
sister gets kind of mad it's like you
know if you don't want to help us why
don't you just say that when you know
whatever just hang out here by the tree
and we'll just go back to work and leave
you here yeah so that was that but then
so they weren't ready to move into the
house yet because they were still
working on it so they were staying with
either I think it was actually Debbie's
mom they were staying with I'm not quite
sure about that cuz I think Arnie's mom
was the one that was gonna move in with
them right and I think that was two
different women like two different
actresses so they're staying in Debbie's
mom's house until the house is ready for
them to move into so evidently either
that same night or a couple nights later
the kid comes running out like in the
middle of the night you know or late at
night and he's like oh the old man he's
in my room and he says he's gonna hurt
me and he's gonna hurt all of you if you
move into the house like he's telling
you not to move in the
yeah so of course the sister NRT and it
was like shut up man what do you talk
about it's you know what I mean they
just think he's like imagining things
having nightmares or whatever and then
so he's standing there like in the
doorway of the kitchen and apparently
everything started like shakey shaken
dr. gates outburst yeah yeah like a
little glasses and [ __ ]
here's there are some differences in the
made-for-television movie yeah when they
were leaving the place after he after
the old man pushed him he said that he
could see him going across the tops of
the trees following them that's how I
remembered it yeah I think that meant
that that little beast is what he called
him followed him back to the house yeah
and then it was in the house waiting for
him when they showed up there and he was
gone
he's in there he's waiting for me he's
gonna hurt me yeah and then yeah and
then that happened later on then he
starts to have premonitions yeah the
first one he had in there was about the
the door at the rental place yeah at
well it was the place we're gonna move
into yeah the place they're gonna move
into yeah he said that animals were
trying to scratch and get into the into
the into the front door yeah
and later on his parents he and his
parents went down there the next day to
continue cleaning they saw the scratches
yeah there were scratch marks and that
convinced the mom she was like how could
he have known that that right animal
tried to get in so they decided didn't
want to stay there yeah this is like
very rare on episodes of a haunting she
got away cuz that's it and even though I
mean they argued because you know Debbie
was like you know she'd already paid two
months rent in advance but seeing the
scratches on the door and seeing how
freaked out the kid was they were like
okay well we can't move in here now
which is something that never happens
because usually they're just like [ __ ]
it we have to stay here because we don't
have enough money or whatever or
nothing's going on blah blah blah but
they just took it seriously enough to
said okay we're not gonna move in there
we're just gonna stay in the house with
Debbie's mom now apparently Arnie's mom
who was supposed to move into the rental
house with them yeah was very annoyed
and she's like losing her roommates yeah
she's like whatever I thought we were
all gonna move in together and she's
like nothing's going on the kids just
freaking out or whatever so she's like
well [ __ ] you
I'll just move in here by myself right
now they kind of like they kind of put
her on the back burner I feel like
because but later on in the episode you
find out that she just like took off cuz
like they went back to the rental house
and she wasn't in there anymore and all
her furniture and [ __ ] was gone so I
don't know she just like [ __ ]
disappeared or they clarified what
happened they didn't really say like
where she went
it just said like because you think
that's his mom I mean I think that she
would have called and said hey I'm out
of here
anyway what they did what they have done
is they've kind of set up this weird
situation where the kid can't move into
the new rental home because the Beast is
telling that he'll attack him if he
moves in there yeah so instead they stay
back at the old place and this beast has
moved into the old place so they're
damned if they do the damned that they
don't yeah and it's in there torment
yeah and weird stuff happens he starts
uh being attacked it looks like you know
like Sony was beating him and they were
trying to his stepdad and his mom are
trying to help him but they're just seen
him being tossed around like he's been
kicked in the gut and he's saying that
you know that that man is beating him up
you know yes that's not his mom it's his
sister sister sorry yeah um it's anyway
it's kind of like the way I'm
interpreting what's going on here this
sounds like classic poltergeist to me
yeah right because possession is often
misdiagnosed or you mean you know
poltergeist is often misdiagnosed as
possession you know in fact you know the
the story that the story that inspired
the movie The Exorcist you know was
based on a true yeah story and as I
listened to the accounts of the priest
that was involved or it wasn't that
priest was the little assistant to the
priest he saw it and he he thought was
poltergeist now that he had known more
about you know what poltergeist is you
know moving objects and you know just
yes I think it is
although I should say that like watching
the episode of a haunting I mean most of
the stuff was focused around very
possession looking stuff it's like there
wasn't a great deal of pull
a guy's activity in the sense of like
stuff flying around and stuff
there were like things with like shaking
and vibrating it like a few things kind
of flew around but mostly it was
centered on him like he would have you
know unexplained bruises and scratches
he would move
he would be like contorted and like
weird ways are like a couple accounts
had him levitating I don't know if they
mentioned but he would he could also
know things that you know he wouldn't
have known yes that happens in
poltergeist ooh yeah because it's
viewing it seems like I don't know if
the glass whole family or if Arnie
Johnson were particularly religious
beforehand but honestly as it didn't
take long um like I said they pretty
much took it seriously from the get-go I
think it was only it was probably like
less than two weeks later like after the
kid first started acting weird that they
actually called the Warrens yeah I don't
know where they knew of the Warrens from
maybe they knew of them from the
Amityville case I mean they were quite
famous at the time so
and they lived nearby you know they
lived in the Connecticut area so maybe
they had a way of finding cases or their
way into cases yeah so I'm not really
sure like in a haunting episode you know
they were like oh let's contact that
nice you know that nice couple that
helped get rid of whatever you know MIT
was the Smurl family or something a
camera what you're there and in the
made-for-tv movie guess who's playing
Edie Warren Andy Griffith yeah how could
you think that is casting somebody they
changed all their names yeah but that's
but it was pretty much exactly what they
said happened but everyone's names were
different maybe they thought were they
were gonna get into legal trouble or
something gave them license to kind of
embellish on this story quite a bit
because the made-for-tv movie is over
the top it's over the top it is yeah
it's it's hard to know exactly you know
what what was reported in this case by
the witnesses and what was kind of made
up by the directors of the TV series I
did read there was actually um you know
when the whole murder trial happened
later on the New York Times weren't like
a big long thing about it you know
was in all the papers and stuff because
it was like you know a defense that no
one had used at least in this country
and so a lot of people did like a lot of
rings so there were actually quotes like
from people on the stand and stuff like
that so some of the stuff that you see
in the episode of haunting and in the TV
movie the TV movie as you know wacky as
it is is actually closer to what
actually happened according to the
witnesses a haunting like I said it was
pretty much the entire thing was focused
on the kid David yeah and he you know he
would get creepier and creepier looking
with his big bags under his eyes and
[ __ ] like that and he was like couldn't
sleep anymore and he started talking in
a weird voice and thrashing around and
whatnot you know what they were reported
though it really kind of struck me is
that they just just said he was just so
overcome with terror all the time in
fear yeah I mean it he couldn't help him
but you know with my experiences with
them you know in Mammoth Mountain and
everything I can kind of really
understand you know like I can kind of
relate to that I think this was
basically poltergeist this is the same
thing I went through his was just
different didn't manifest itself the
same way yeah and like I said I'm not
sure how really because when they got
the warrants to come over like the first
time the Warrens came they showed on on
a haunting and worn like trips on the
steps yeah and like I was making a joke
like did they just leave that in and not
do a second take or what but then like
you see later on like when they come in
the kids showing his premonition powers
by saying you tripped on the steps on
the way in here and there were only a
demon could have known that because I
was like making a joke like yeah we
heard you but yes I seem to remember I
seem to remember there was more to his
abilities than that he could ask
questions about objects and know who
gave that to to you things like that
yeah because when um I think Arnie went
to because some of the problem arose
when you know the kid is going through
all this you know rigmarole with the you
know they purported demon and Arnie was
getting who's not related it's this is
his girlfriend's brother but apparently
he's you know
was his little buddy and you know and
everything so he would start like
taunting the demon like to come into him
right and then he kind of started acting
weird too but like so he went to a
priest and was did the priest to give
him the the crucifix er that has been
blessed by it I know I knew who gave
that to you that's not gonna help yeah
and when he came back to the house then
the kid said I know where you've been
and I know who gave you that and then
apparently the chain broke and the and
the thing went flying across and on
another program Edie Warren said that
that kid he could question that kid and
that could that kid could tell you
exactly how much money you had in your
pocket yeah I can do things like that
how much you had in your pocket and then
you could know he could he could answer
detailed you know I mean give you
detailed answers yeah like you know what
somebody's phone number is that kind of
stuff now see that might have because I
haven't seen that at any other but
that's it Warren this that's what I mean
because ed and Lorraine Warren at wrote
a book about this case that came out in
82 or 83 and you know they might have
had you know if you've seen our show on
the Warrens
you know they seemed like nice people or
at least Lorraine did but it was nice he
was just a man of his time yeah I I do
feel like if they were gonna add some
[ __ ] to make [ __ ] more exciting then
they would do that yeah yeah they had a
vested interest in it you know religions
involved with this and yeah and so was
you know this was another era and you
could make a lot of money off the
paranormal back then yeah you could make
a lot of money going on talk shows yeah
that doesn't exist anymore you really
can't make money with this way you could
back then and actually I question how
much money you could actually make from
it I think they were all just trying to
replicate the amount of money that was
made with the Amityville Horror
yeah and that was the big one and that
was like lightning in a bottle I felt
like you read that email like everybody
was trying it's like yeah my [ __ ]
house is haunted - yeah I got demons
come you know come write a book about my
house know some of those kids were later
dollars some of those cases were better
than others
yeah but they I don't
they weren't all true you know and
honestly I've heard that the Glassell
family from the book that the Warrens
wrote about this case I think they only
got a couple thousand dollars yeah
which isn't nothing but a Lutz family
only got it maybe like a hundred
thousand three hundred so they didn't
become millionaires yeah it wasn't like
you know millionaire and make it rain
kind right now that was a lot of money
back then I heard they burned through it
pretty quickly too as you do yeah when
you've been poor your whole life
suddenly somebody hands you 300 grand
Martita I would really really try not to
do that I promise if somebody wants to
give me $300,000 we'll try that out but
yeah so like I said a lot of it focused
around like the Warrens are trying to
get an exorcism for the kid but
obviously they have all these like rules
and you have to go through the bishop
and stuff and they had to go like
through a psychiatrist they always do
that kind of [ __ ] now apparently the kid
was normal the only thing they found was
like a slight learning disability that
was about the only thing that was wrong
with them he was normal in every other
way but evidently they got some priests
to come in and do a couple minor rites
of exorcism as they call it because you
don't need permission for that I guess
now there's the warrants said that they
requested like the big deal exorcism but
the Catholic Church in the area says no
they never asked so I don't know who to
believe because neither one of those
worthy but they said they never asked
and then the warrants came back and said
well we have it on tape
that we asked you hmm so I'm just kind
of like but I don't know if they've ever
played the days so I don't know maybe
they're just trying to the warrants had
ways you know that's what I mean so I
don't really know how but in any case
they didn't do they did I think they did
like three minor rites of exorcism on
the kid but like I said the problem
arose and they showed this like most of
the middle part of a haunting episode
was just the kid you know acting
possessed that's pretty much all it was
and then there's some point where Arnie
says hey leave the kid alone come in to
me yeah then the black contact lenses
come
yeah and then you know they had Arnie
Cheyenne Johnson and Debbie Glassell who
married later on and they had both of
them talking and she said that he
started acting very weird you know so
they had this one scene where she's like
in the rental house apparently they had
gone back to the rental house to see
whatever happened I already is mom and
she's just [ __ ] gone like I said they
never did specify like where she went or
if she contacted just like yeah I'm a
[ __ ] missing person yeah it's not
clear so there's something fishy with
that element of the story that's what
I'm saying they didn't really because
all down it would be that my mom's like
they're full of [ __ ] there was no ghosts
you know it might have been something
like that so they just try to leave her
out of the story but really I kind of
think there's in general something to
this story yeah yeah I don't know I
think certain aspects of it might have
been played up by you know the Warrens
continued by the people that are making
a television series or a television
program and then you know the people
from a haunting they're all gonna kind
of push this story into a direction that
they want it to go in you know what they
think will be a hit with the audience
it's really what it was down to but I
have a feeling this happened I think was
poked guy's too though yeah yeah I think
it's weird because at the end of the
show like I said so Arnie is pretty much
hey come into me and then suddenly
they're like oh well David's fine you
know cuz the demons not in him anymore
even though I think and I don't know if
they mentioned this on a haunting or not
but the Warren said that he had like 42
demons or 43 demons you know there's
always more demons you can't just have
one
[Laughter]
but yeah so they had a couple scenes
where they go back to the rental house
and you know Debbie is in the house and
then Arnie comes back in and his eyes
are all black and he looks like he's
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of her something
like that she's like all right what's
the matter with you and then he comes to
and then he's like how did I get in here
I was outside because what he says
happened is that there was this old well
behind the rental house and the kid told
him about it right but yeah yeah they
started calling him the Beast and then
later he started looking
like an actual devil with the horns and
he was all black and [ __ ] like that yeah
so evidently the kid told him that's
where he comes from he lives in the well
or he that's where he enters our
dimension or whatever and so I guess
that Arnie went back there and he saw
the Beast like standing by the well yeah
it's a pretty good eye contact and
that's when the demon like took him over
yeah as well it's a pretty cool scene in
the haunting episode yeah he goes back
out there you know and it's standing out
there in the woods
yeah and then he wakes up later and you
know he'd almost attacked his wife you
know his girlfriend
yeah now isn't that that's pretty much
where they ended the episode of a
haunting there was something else to
happen remember happened he got into
that car in that car nearly killed him
he saw that he saw the the the the Beast
there pointed at the car with him in it
and then go like that and then it like
yeah car took off he lost control but he
regained control somehow yeah he didn't
when he went to the went to the priest
about it to help get the exorcism he
said he saw it you know he said look
look just like the devil and look just
like the devil so if mr. hater horns and
[ __ ]
yeah and that's how they showed it on
the show it looked like a creepy shadow
would look and you know but that's how
they described it later on like ohms and
horns and everything but yeah so then
that seems like that's about where the
haunting episode ended even though
that's when it actually got interesting
I'm not sure why they left it out
because like I said they had Debby
glottal and yeah
Arnie Cheyenne Johnson on there talking
and they did not bring it up I mean
they're much older now obviously because
the show came out in 2006 and all this
happened like in 1980 1981 so I want to
do this part on the second half yeah
we're gonna talk about we'll talk about
the TV movie and we'll talk about the
actual case like what actually happened
after that because like I said that's
when it kind of got interesting and you
know the whole trial it's actually quite
famous so we'll get into that on the
second half of the show so we will be
back in just a few minutes okay
everybody ginnis guys a new shirt
designs up four of them really good ones
to Atlanta Ripper who put Bello in the
witch
the HH Holmes murder castle and of
course demon child cuz man said he could
these are updated designs I think they
look really cool Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making jetty
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them links
in the description WWL com at 13 o'clock
yes ago check out our store at wwl comm
slash 13 o'clock we got these four cool
new t-shirt designs plus all our old
ones if you'd rather get one of the old
ones but these ones are awesome and you
should check them out they're also
available in women's cotton they look
really cute JD's got some so thank you
go check them out
all right we are back doing a recap of
the episode of a haunting known as where
demons dwell and also talking about the
stuff that happened later on that wasn't
on the show yeah that's actually known
as it's usually noted the devil made me
do it case or the demon murder case kind
of famous in American jurisprudence but
yeah so what ended up happening after
the events of haunting was that Debbie
Glassell and Arnie Cheyenne Johnson they
actually moved into this apartment that
was owned by Debbie's employer whose
name was Alan bono now he owned like a
dog kennel she was a dog groomer so they
moved into this apartment and I'm not
really sure it wasn't very long like
after they had moved in now Alan Bona
was actually much older I think Arnie
like I said was only 19
Alan bono I think it was in his 40s and
the TV movie actually made it seem like
this kind of made me laugh because I
don't know the name of the actor that
played quote-unquote Alan bono in a
different name in the movie but they
made him like the most obnoxious showed
in the history of the world that's what
I mean and I was just like please kill
that guy oh my god Arnie from this story
you know
all right he ends up killing that dude
yeah now nice tune now in this contest
Horry all right it's kind of
understandable but yeah you wouldn't you
wouldn't expect that you know I mean
this see but that's what I was gonna say
the the TV movie portrayed it like that
but according to everything I've read
about it that wasn't exactly
I mean evidently Alan Bono and Arnie
Johnson were buds okay um in the movie
they made it look like like they're in
kind of an anti like they were an tat
like they hated each other and that Alan
Bona was like trying to put the moves on
our knees girlfriend Debbie I got any
gays yeah I haven't really read anywhere
where'd that happen now what happened on
this particular fateful day yeah um
Arnie Johnson was actually he was like
he was did a tree service type stuff he
was like a tree surgeon or whatever now
on this particular day he decided that
he was gonna call in sick because he
wanted to like hang out with
I think his little sister and like a
couple of their little cousins or
whatever and they were all gonna go hang
out at the at the kennel where Debbie
worked and Allan bono was also there now
at some point he's like hey let's go to
this restaurant slash bar nearby for
lunch now evidently while they're having
lunch Allan bono gets very very
intoxicated some sources say say that
Arnie Johnson also got very intoxicated
but some said he wasn't intoxicated that
he was still fairly sober so but so it
seems like it's kind of getting to a
point where shit's bad because there's
like a bunch of little kids like you
know like I said I think Arnie's sister
was only nine or something like that
there was this so it's like a little 9
10 11 12 year old girls yeah and so
Debbie is sitting there going man Alan's
getting super [ __ ] up and it's like
this is probably not gonna end well so
they leave the restaurant and I don't
know this always this part always
confused me but like after they left the
restaurant and went back to the the
kennel then Debbie takes the girls to
get pizza I'm like were they not yet a
restaurant yeah I thought but some see
some sources say bar maybe it was just a
bar yeah but you can't take little
things in a bar could be that you know
there was a trial involved and they're
trying to make a TV movie about this
they kinda wanna soften the characters a
little bit no they weren't at a bar they
were at a restaurant we're gonna put
that in a TV movie it looked like a
regular black dance yeah but every other
account I've said pretty much just said
bar yeah they were in a bar so they're
bright eating at a bar yeah you can't
eat at somebody and you know maybe the
kids didn't maybe there wasn't anything
there they wanted to eat I don't know
they said why don't you take us to go
get pizza later on maybe they left
before the food got there
maybe they left before they actually
were oh yeah me maybe the kids got super
drunk and get them wasn't enough
information so they left and she takes
the kids to go get pizza evidently I
don't know if Allen had kept drinking or
what but he was like starting to get
kind of belligerent so Debbie comes back
with the girls and then in the meantime
Allen and Arnie have gotten into an
altercation now
debbie is like trying to get the girls
out of there she's like and she's kind
of trying to get in the middle of the
two of them and like I said if you read
if you read stuff about the trial and
everything like that like all the little
girls like testified like a Debbie
testified and with all these people
testified and what happened that day so
you know so Debbie's sure Debbie's
trying to get in the middle of the two
guys like hey don't fight or whatever
and then apparently Debbie's trying to
get the little girls out of there and
Allen Bono grabs one of the kids I think
it was either Wanda or Mary she was like
a nine year old and she just he just
like grabbed her he's like I'm not
letting her go like whatever he was
acting like totally weird
at which point Arnie pulls out like I
guess it was like a pocketknife or
something that he had and start stabbing
so he stabbed Allen Bono a bunch I think
it was five times in the gut and he
pretty man one of the stabs like he
stabbed him in the stomach and then like
pulled it up like toward his heart yeah
Arnie the Ripper I guess so now Allen
bono didn't die right away like they
called the cops now Arnie ran off now
apparently all of the witnesses said
that when he ran off he was like acting
like animalist so he was growling and
stuff this is they were trying to do the
defensive play later on that he was
possessed yes yeah cuz like I said you
know he was the one that said the
David's demon to come in him and
evidently it really did so the Beast now
this is the thing that wasn't clear
though when the demon when he called the
demon out of the kid did the haunting
stop or did the poltergeist see they
just kind of paper data they just kind
of yeah what happened to the to the
guys cased yeah I think yes I have a
feeling it just kind of burned out on
its own maybe yeah and now I'm kind of
wondering like when they did the
exorcisms on the kid he supposedly had
4243 demons crowded in there yeah and
what they do just like kick him out one
at a time did all of them go into Arnie
or just one I have so many questions you
guys I just you know so in in Arnie's
story the demon went into him before the
exorcism happened know after after the
exorcism so well there was more than one
exorcism okay it was a long series of
exorcisms day I think yeah I think it
was three okay
and then they were just like I said it
wasn't a big deal exorcism like that you
need the approval of it so it's just
kind of demonic leakage see Monica Lee
one of them somehow got into Arnie yes
it's just you know it might leakage yeah
it's just like you know what I mean when
you just it's just like a tiny little
fart that gets out yeah except it's a
demon okay coming out of your penis yeah
so and then it goes in someone else's
mouth and well I was just that just
reminded me the other day was it
yesterday where baby cookie was sleeping
under the covers with you and farted
right in your face yeah yeah she likes
she's a tunnel kids and then farts in
your face yeah I am I live in fear of
her doing that because she likes to
sleep on my pillow with the head of her
little butt sort of so I'm always kind
of like scared that I'm gonna wake up
you know so far coming at me back to
this things you know during this he's
claiming that during these exorcisms one
of these demons got into him because he
called it in to him yeah because he was
basically saying you know for the demons
to leave the kid alone you know he was
trying to be big and bad yeah
it's funny because you know and they
said this on the haunting episode to
where everybody he said you know the
warrants told him all the priests know
it's like a whole don't ever do that
don't challenge the demon to like coming
to you because he will yeah and he did
evidently but yes so so Artie runs off
like I said and they said he was acting
like an amaz very very funny in the TV
movie version cuz this is Kevin Bacon
with his Footloose hair like I said and
he's like crawling over like on all
fours like over a rock or something like
run away he's goin footloose but yeah
but yeah so they take Ellen Bunner to
the hospital he dies a couple hours
later from his injuries and then they
find Arnie and Arnie says that he
doesn't remember what happened now did
the gut was the guy able to make a
statement before he died I don't think
so yeah um not that I ever heard like I
think he just think what started
bleeding when unconscious and they took
him then he just kind of slipped away I
think is what happened but yeah so they
pick Arnie up and he's just kind of like
it's weird because he says he didn't
remember what happened and he just like
woke up and he was somewhere else like
two miles away I think he ran away
keeping himself from having to testify
right so there was that whole thing now
when he when his [ __ ] was gonna go to
trial
his lawyer whose name was Mark Martin or
Marvin Mennella
I think was his name he decides that
he's going to go with the devil made me
do it defense now this had never been
attempted in the United States before
for obvious reasons but this lawyer
actually found two you know cases from
England I'm not sure what years they
were from fifteen hundred yeah that's
what I was thinking I'm like although it
was only two cases maybe they work at a
reason because you think from the 1600s
that would be like all the cases you
know what I mean it's like yeah it was
it was the devil oh okay yeah yeah yeah
so he found two cases from England where
that was used as a defense I don't know
if it was successful or not but so he
decides ding that's one
I'm gonna do so he comes to the judge
he's like this is the defense blah blah
blah and he said he's gonna he's got the
Warrens are gonna testify because they
were totally um it should be noted that
before
Arnie killed anybody the Warrens
apparently called the police and said
something Bad's gonna happen over there
because that dude's possessed and he's
acting super weird because before this
according to all accounts
Arnie Johnson have been totally normal
really nice dude totally laid-back and
this has entered into evidence and in
the trial get warrants had called the
police before and warned yeah
wow that that's you know that's an
interesting yesterday John said they
didn't specify but they said something
Bad's gonna happen in the family right
like either something Bad's gonna happen
to them or one of them it's gonna do
something that's very interesting that
Lawrence called it well they've been
hanging out with them for a long time so
they probably knew that [ __ ] was gonna
boil over at some stage and maybe Arnie
was acting super weird because I don't
know like every like I said I've read a
lot of accounts of this and they said
you know Arnie was just a normal you
know normal working-class Joe he's
really nice and laid-back and everything
but then after that whole you know I
looked at the Beast by the well type
thing then he starts acting kind of
weird off and on he got in trouble for
like minor petty crimes and [ __ ] like
stealing [ __ ] I guess well I think he
got involved in the poltergeist case he
actually saw a poltergeist phenomenon
and maybe saw some spectral apparitions
that happened you know and he got caught
up in the moment I think it traumatized
him that's what I think happened maybe
he did believe he was possessed well he
saw soon have he seems to have seen
possession in this kid he believed it so
yeah he thought that he's possessed in
that and like I said I don't let him to
doing weird things it's not clear how
religious this family was beforehand but
the fact that they called the Warrens
pretty much immediately leads me to
believe that they probably were inclined
in that direction because that's not
normally but you would do I don't even
know if they took the kid to a
psychiatrist
did later and actually after that
happened they actually put the kid in a
home for a little while for like
emotionally disturbed children even
though psychiatrists looked him over and
said all he has a slight learning
disability he's totally fine now here's
something that was not on the haunting
episode and it was not in the TV movie
either but this was in the New York
Times and it was in a couple of other
accounts of the case that were written
at the time another thing that they said
was a symptom of David Glassell being
possessed was that he gained 60 pounds
in just like a few months a fatter
muscle fat damn so an even and there was
a quote that was from the courtroom
where Debbie Glassell said one of the
reasons that they thought that he was
legit possessed was because one of the
things he would do is he would do like
all these crazy like really fast sit-ups
and they're like and she said quote
unquote he couldn't do that normally
because he was too fat he was like obese
it was only 11 I mean 60 pounds when
you're 11 gaining 60 pounds in you're 11
years old yeah that's yeah they said he
got really really obese like in a really
short time so they attributed that to
Daman and I thought that was kind of
interesting that they didn't put it in
either I mean I can see why they didn't
cuz it would be like you know they'd
have to give the kid a fat suit yeah but
because the kid that was in a haunting
episode was like yes he's gay but yeah
so that was something that I discovered
that yeah so that was one of the things
because they said he just did all this
acrobatic [ __ ] that there's no way he
could do it cuz he was too fat and his
sister says that's interesting
but yeah so they thought that was the
DIA obvious like well that's 42 demons
weighs 60 pounds now you know you say 60
pounds of muscle is it man give me
whatever that kids all these new
performance enhancements yeah so like I
said they try to go to trial with this
devil made me do it defense essentially
so just like you know and they have they
we have all these priests that were at
the exorcisms that we can subpoena we
have all of their testimony and all this
other stuff now evidently the the lawyer
had gone to all this trouble like
preparing this defense they present it
to the judge at the I'm not entirely
sure how it works but like at the
indictment or whatever and the judge is
like no you're not doing that he's like
because he's like there's no way he's
like he called it unscientific it's just
you can't prove that someone was
possessed by a demon and then the
lawyers like man come on it's like I
spent a lot of time I worked really hard
on this yeah
and he's like and I have all these
witnesses I've you know the Warrens and
those and everybody was at the exorcism
and they all saw like he levitated and
did all this like you know his body was
all contorting and like unnatural
positions and [ __ ] like that
so the judge just was not having it so
he said no you can't do that so then and
I don't know why he went for the obvious
demon maybe he's trying to like get
famous or whatever I don't know why he
went for demon possession when [ __ ]
self defense was right there because he
is allen bono was super drunk yeah he
grabbed a little kid apparently
according all the witnesses and wouldn't
let her go I mean you would think that
you would argue self-defense well you
can get in defense of others yeah you
know I mean she's a little kid and it's
like you know I was rescuing the girl
right yeah it's like most people would
have gone yeah it's called the cab
save-a-ho defense captain save-a-ho
defense I'm gonna jump in there and save
her yeah most people watch the dude yeah
I mean maybe stabbing him is a little
bit over the top but you know you can't
blame the dude and I don't know how
drunk Arnie Johnson was either you know
what it depends if there was a size
difference to maybe you know maybe he
knew the dude was dangerous safe was the
best way yeah there's a lot of things
involved in these self-defense cases
that are kind of gray yeah you had to be
there and in the moment and understand
the motivations and the characters
involved the backstory you know the
context yes always you know that's
that's the Devils in the details
with these things
that was pretty good yeah not only do I
have the jar out it's a main character
in this show I got the table that the
jar sits on and it's the size of the jar
it's also not very steady and I just
live in fear of that table just going to
God I got that table down to a science
that's my jar table yeah because it's
like it really it's that table is not
really meant to put anything on because
it's very lightweight and it's like
that's all it is it's just like a little
like a pretty table in the corner in
case you want a little vase on it or
something but yeah so so the lawyer
finally has he's like okay well I'll
backtrack and I'll use the self defense
ploy because you know Arnie was trying
to save the little girl or so he claimed
so that's the defense they went with now
they were going the prosecutors were
actually going for a first-degree murder
or maybe second-degree murder I'm
actually not sure um but yeah I think
it's been three minutes yeah first was
premeditated that's what I'm saying
second is yeah but what they ended up
doing with the jury now he was found
guilty but of a lesser charge of
manslaughter now they the max sentence
for manslaughter and the judge gave him
the max sentence was 10 to 20 years
however he actually served less than
five years before going out on parole
now according to all sources all the
prison prison officials everything like
that he was an exemplary prisoner
they said he was just never got any
trouble he was totally fine he actually
got his GED while he was in jail he
married Debbie Glassell they got married
while he was in prison he also got
several educational certificates and he
was let out really really early because
of good behavior and has apparently not
committed a crime since it was a
situational homicide that's what I mean
I feel like and if he had been drinking
and if the you know the little girl was
involved and there was I don't know what
they were fighting I don't think was
manslaughter I think it was defense of
others actually that's what I mean I
don't even think I would have done you
know had they not tried to go the whole
devil made me
do it route he probably I would've beat
it he might have beaten that round if
they had hit hard on it but because the
media is surrounding it you know there
was such hype surrounding it because
they were like oh the defense attorneys
gonna try to say that he was possessed
and that's you know and that's never
been done before and so there was like a
media [ __ ] circus I was the defense I
would have said that it was defense of
others yeah he was belligerent he had
that little girl wouldn't let it go
yeah and he thought that in that moment
he thought that guy was gonna do
something bad to that girl right then
right he had to just which is completely
reasonable and then what the intent
wasn't to kill he just stabbed him to
get the girl to get the girl away yeah
yeah that's what I mean and I feel like
the defense was really dumb because why
yeah you know why would you he probably
for such a wacky defense and then you
know the case is so tainted because it
turns out in the media it's like oh this
guy is trying to argue that he got
[ __ ] possessed by demons and that's
why he stabbed that dude you know what I
mean and it's like when they could have
just said you know there were
extenuating circumstances and they
should have hit that hard and like not
even you know you probably would have
got off I mean as it was like I said he
served less than five years and then he
got out you know him as far as I know
him and Debbie Glassell are still
married to this day they interviewed
both of them on a haunting and they
talked about it but here's the thing the
Warrens like I said wrote a book about
this case I believe that was what they
used as the basis for the for the
terrible wonderful Kevin Bacon book it
was that NBC yeah um in 1983 but later
on David Glassell once he got grown up
him and his brother
sued the Warrens because they said all
of that stuff in the book was [ __ ]
yeah the book they said yeah they just
made it up to because they they said oh
well they told the family that you would
get all this money Berman it's just like
Amityville Horror
um and the brother of David glass I
think his name was Karl I want to say he
said you know you guys were just
exploiting like my brother's mental
illness because like I said the little
boy like after this whole incident they
put him in a little in a home for
emotionally disturbed children for
little
but you know he was alright after that
so the brother was trying to argue like
emotional distress and you know you guys
made up all this stuff about my family
they tried to make the brother look like
a villain in the book because he didn't
believe any of it and so in the book
apparently I haven't read it but the
Warrens kind of made Karl look like the
devil incarnate himself so the brother
didn't believe anything paranormal was
going on no no he thought it was all a
bunch of [ __ ] everybody else did
yeah and then yeah and it's weird
because and David glad so like I said
you know when he grew up he said that it
was [ __ ] and then he was just like
mentally ill and they were taking
advantage no the kid yes so I'm not
really sure how that and they sued I
don't they don't I don't think they won
actually but there was this just this
big thing and now there's like this like
familial rift okay between you know
Arnie and Debby who still claim that it
happened and the Warrens who still claim
that it happened I mean oh so the kid
claims that he was mentally managed like
mentally ill and then the family and the
Warrens
were conspiring to make money off his
mental illness with this case yeah
that's what they were arguing when they
sued they said that you know they said
the Warrens were trying to exploit David
glass olds mental illness at the time
like he was going through some emotional
problems and they were you know making
it seem like demonic possession now he
was a little kid I'm not sure how old
witch follows that when he went when
what's-his-name stabbed that guy he went
ahead and go oh you know what it was
that it was that demon yeah so okay it's
interesting was all fraud yeah so there
but like I said both which I which
explains why he's not on the haunting
episode well yeah yeah that yeah that's
exactly why so it's like both sides were
like at odds but they both like stuck to
their guns over the years like with
their side of the story right okay and
you know as far as I know that's kind of
where it stands and like you said that
the haunting episode came out in 2006
and the only two people that are
interviewed for it they interviewed
Lorraine Warren because you know as soon
as a haunting calls she's gonna turn up
on there so she was on there and Debbie
Glassell was on there
and Arne Johnson was on there the weird
thing is like when I'm looking for
pictures for this episode and I think I
[ __ ] it up on our warrens one but
whenever you Wikipedia are you uh are
you look for pictures of Arne Cheyenne
Johnson most of the pictures that come
up are not him hmm and I'm like I'm
looking at pictures and I'm like what is
not that does not look like him it's
like who is that guy
like really there's only cuz the guy
that's on a haunting is apparently him
like the real guy and it just don't look
anything like the pictures hmm and it's
weird because they show um you know
trial of Barney Cheyenne Johnson in the
picture that comes up I just like this
older guy with gray hair and glasses and
sometimes he has like little orange
jumpsuit on he's in a courtroom but he's
older he's like in his 40s or 50s it's
like Arnie was only 19 or 20 at the
trial I mean that happened when he was
young
so pretty much all I found from there
because I guess back in the day you
couldn't take pictures in a classroom so
all I found is like courtroom sketches
of him and he's like a young blond guy
yeah cause like I said he was only 19
it's weird the family the story that
they tell fits with the pattern around
poltergeist phenomena yeah I wonder if
the story that they're telling is what
the kid actually said you know he's
gonna get me you know or the earth they
made that up out of whole cloth you know
it's hard it's hard to it's hard to say
now now that I know that the kid has
come forth to say that no I was mentally
ill the family was making that up he may
be telling the truth yeah I mean he was
just 11 when it happened
he might I mean there's a possibility
maybe he's in denial maybe he was
hanging out with his brother and his
brother was like man that's a bunch of
[ __ ] they [ __ ] you over could be
that the family kind of constructed this
story you know what I mean under under
the supervision of the Warrens yeah and
I feel like that's that's something that
comes an accusation that comes up a lot
around the war around them that they
will kind of like waltz into a situation
or they'll get called there and then
they deliberately they think oh I you
know we can make a lecture series or we
can write a book about this and they'll
kind of hype it that way to the family
and
tell the family to change the story that
you know what I mean it's like oh this
could be a book it could be a movie you
could be taken care of forever it'll be
like The Amityville Horror you'll be
millionaires and all of this other stuff
because I have I mean this case is not
the first time that that accusation has
come up against them like I said I don't
know how true it is I've never met them
but it is something that is out there
that some families have said about them
and like I said you know we were talking
about it on the show I probably
mentioned it on the show about Anfield
where you know ed and Lorraine Warren
like showed up one day yeah they try to
barge into the inn and we're not they
weren't invited they just showed up
there and then you know subsequently now
you have like the conjuring and
everything like that or the concern to
which make it makes it look like they
were the two people investigating it
when they were there for one day they
weren't invited the investigators told
them basically they were kicked out of
there yeah it's like this isn't your
investigation get out of here
and so but the conjuring to you makes it
look like they were like the main
investigators was like they just showed
up on the doorstep no one want to get
involved
the definitive end field case if the
source material is this house is haunted
we have the book yeah as an excellent
excellent book well like I said that's
kind of what that was like the template
yeah I bought it I it's not I don't know
if it's imprinting more it probably is
now because um since the conjuring 2
came out yeah that's like an old library
book is that a print when I bought it I
first found this book when I was a kid
after my experience with infielder when
I read this man is just bam bam bam it
just rang so true it was so close to dry
very dry it's not exaggerated and it's
got shitty reviews oh it's not exciting
God doesn't answer anything that's the
way the cases really are that's if you
want it if you want it this is the one
you want to read and no we didn't write
this this guy paper this is just like
last year I think but yeah so that's the
thing about this case that and can we
please just talk about a little bit
about the [ __ ] TV movie cuz you guys
it's still on YouTube now if you want to
go away go watch it it's called the
demon
our case yeah it's from 1983 it was on
NBC and like I said it's an all-star
cast man Andy Griffith plays the Ed
Warren character like I said all the
names are different but it's like pretty
much exactly the same and it's just the
it's just everybody everybody and it was
familiar to me like I'd seen every actor
yeah and something else Cloris Leachman
was in it although I felt like she was
kind of shoehorned in because all her
she was like a journalist that was like
covering the trial so she was only in it
for like a couple of scenes yeah but you
know what did they this was another
thing and it this was kind of a problem
too that a haunting that the haunting
episode had I remember this being one of
the best episodes from the first couple
seasons but I didn't realize how much of
it is just focusing on oh the kids
possessed and like doing exorcisms and
[ __ ] and I think the same thing happened
with the TV movie because it seemed like
at least 40 minutes of that [ __ ] yeah
was the kid like going in those days
that was the money shot I got some
people wanted to see because that's you
know they saw the Exorcist they wanted
more that witch in The Exorcist it
worked
yeah because there was variety to the
[ __ ] she was doing you know what I mean
so it was like kind of scary this one
was just kind of like oh it's the kid
talking in cookie monster voice and
we're in a you know a church with like
all these candles and it's done on a
television budget yeah it's like the way
it's shot is shot like it's shot like
community theater community television
it is but like I said they got some big
stars to be in this yeah I mean I guess
at the time was Kevin Bacon a big star
93 he was well he was in Footloose that
was 1984 and I think a breakout role he
was he was coming up because [ __ ] was it
he was in any burger that was Andy
Griffith was a has-been at this time
that's true yeah Kevin Oh Kevin Bacon
was in um [ __ ] he was in one of the
slasher movies right well Friday the
13th - was it Friday the 13th yeah it
wasn't a guy from the guy yeah it was
one of those yeah good but I remember
that was like before he got famous
so maybe Footloose was like his big
breakout so he was still like doing
these little shitty roles like on TV and
in slasher movies and stuff before he
became like
super famous and the clothes were
getting me getting to me too in that one
of the shoulder pads and the women with
the frilly collars of the yeah that was
one thing it very very Baptist didn't
they yeah very bad one thing about the
80s and this is something I never eat
succumb to in the 80s and I did succumb
to some fashion victim [ __ ] in the 80s
I'm not saying that but one thing I
never liked was shoulder pads and you
you bought [ __ ] in the 80s and it all
had shoulder pads and you had to cut him
out I had to cut him out cuz I'm like I
ever do though I have big shoulders and
big arms it's like I don't need more
bulk it's like I'm gonna look like a
[ __ ] linebacker coming at you I don't
need that [ __ ] so it's it you know what
I mean like I a lot of the
weird I'm like all these fashion choices
like I know what the thought behind it
was but in the execution
waist look smaller you know [ __ ] like
that but it's just on most people it
just didn't have that effect early
eighties almost kind of like in a Soviet
era you go to a mall alright and it was
just the same things on all the racks
everywhere that same look and it was
like third-world quality back then
remember yeah look at some that [ __ ]
today you're like man Americans were
that and you know it's the way it was in
the 80s it's just real cheap cheap
you remember parachute pants yeah I
didn't have any beep and and it wasn't
cheap when you bought it it was check
quality but you know they they were they
were making a killing off you know they
right now I didn't have any parachute
pants but I will admit that I had a pair
of like dark maroon corduroy pants that
have like zippers all over them yeah
you'd need some clothing so where I had
where do I go we have to go to the ball
you go to the mall eating heavy choices
on it you know everything looked the
same yeah basically the dark days before
the energy yeah no no and it was just
like you know yo same ol same ol man you
know what and Hot Topic showed up that
lasted for a little while then that went
bad we didn't even like I grew up in
Daytona Beach which was kind of redneck
it well still have a high yeah well we
didn't have a hot topic until [ __ ] man
late 90s early 2000s I don't think we
had one before that but um it was good
at first you could buy gothic clothes
now it's just all t-shirts and toys I
think it's I think it's gone now um
there's still some but there's not I
think there's one in our mall than
terrible it's not far from here bearable
that's it's funny you just brought up a
memory of when I was in probably I don't
know sixth grade seventh grade something
like that and I was going to some dance
and I remember my grandma and my
great-aunt and they I used to go to the
mall with them all the time when I was
little yeah and so they were gonna go
buy me an outfit for the dance right so
we go to the I don't remember what store
it was it was one of the ones that
grandma's shopped in but I ended up
getting oh Jesus it was like it was this
[ __ ] white dress with like all these
[ __ ]
polka dots all over it they were
turquoise purple and hot pink and yeah
and I and then I got like little
matching bracelets my like remember
those plastic wavy bracelets they like
back together like I got a pink one and
a turquoise one at a perf one I was like
a little I was like when we had to close
fanzines yeah was that um I used to get
I got all of my t-shirts through burning
Airlines okay there was another one too
and there was a couple in the UK there
was one called black rose all the black
rose yeah black rose that was a good one
they actually had a Benson they actually
had a store in Camden Market in London
because I went there when I was in the
UK I don't know if it's still there
probably not but I used to get their
catalogue and stuff and yeah not cheap
I got extra I got a couple nice pieces
like trainer dollars 200 hours for a
jacket velvet yeah cuz well they were
real velvet they were actually like
well-made I thought I couldn't wear me
in the south it burnt yeah that's my
main we live in Florida you can't I have
one velvet jacket I think I've maybe
worn it three times in my whole life
it's just you'll [ __ ] swelter and die
if you wear that [ __ ] down here although
you know like I said let we went out
last night well we might as well tell
this story we went out last night to
independent bar which is kind of our
hangout here they every year they do the
visage reunion if you grew up in Orlando
and are into like goth or alternative
music or punk or anything like that you
have fond memories of the nightclub
known as visage it's obviously not there
anymore
I didn't live here then but yeah you
didn't live here then but I did and I
went there a couple times I guess I saw
Christian death there back in the day so
you know so everybody that's from here
like has really fond memories I've been
really sad when it closed so independent
bars started doing you know right around
Christmas they'll do what they call the
visage reunion and Paul Bain who was the
DJ he will come back and do a set he'll
come out of his self-imposed retirement
him and his wife Tina they're actually
lovely lovely wonderful people and he
will come back and DJ so I was like well
we have to go to that because even
though it gets super super packed every
because everybody comes and it's like
I've seen people I haven't seen in
[ __ ] years and it was just like
wall-to-wall and [ __ ] Paul vain man he
was killed nailed it he killed it
my feet hurt so bad from dancin I danced
so much we drank a loaded man we did it
but it's not a $30 bar tab 139 well we
in our Kela in our defense we got there
early we got there at 8 o'clock yeah cuz
they opened early and we wanted to get
there you know early so we find a place
to park and before it got crowded and
stuff so we got there at 8:00 and then
well you get the double tequila sunrises
and I think those are like 14 bucks each
yeah like that so it adds up yeah and we
were so dude we were there for a long
time yeah patreon my tho yeah honestly
it's like I drank a lot to you but I was
dancing and sweating so much that I
didn't I didn't even really get all that
drunk ID you know yeah but it was a we
had a [ __ ] blast I haven't had that
much fun in a long time and the music
was just amazing yeah I mean I had a
really really good it was good
but yeah so what are we doing on time
okay we probably should wrap this yes
wrap this up alright so hopefully you
know you guys enjoyed this look into the
demon more yeah like I said well I guess
we kind of wrap this up we did this case
I got mixed feelings about it now that
you know Jenny gave me a couple more
details she did this all off the top of
her head there's no no notes here either
just all up the opera head yeah I didn't
know I didn't know that the kid came
forward and said that he was mentally
ill and that the parents made that up
and under the influence of the Warrens
that that may have been that may be true
I kind of suspect and the Warrens would
know how to fake a good case yeah okay
because the story that's shown in the
haunting episode actually fits a lot of
the patterns of of some pretty good
poltergeist cases yeah like I said like
objects flying around you know like you
know the kids just waiting about yeah
and the way it kind of built up and yeah
there's some possessions that [ __ ]
thrown in there but the Exorcist is
based on a poltergeist case it looks
like possession sometimes yeah so but
hearing that now you know I'm kind of
wavering on this either that or the kid
just tried to make make a buck yeah or
maybe he turned his back on the case and
doesn't want to be associated with it
yeah they could be any number of
different thing like I said he made it
happen and but he doesn't want he's he's
into
eyal well that's what I was thinkin or
maybe he fell under the infant because
he was so young when it happened cuz
[ __ ] I don't remember anything that
happened he fell other people that told
him that it was all right that's what I
thought because it was mainly his
brother that brought the lawsuit and his
brother was an unbeliever the whole
entire time so it could be that you know
since he was so little when he got a
little bit older I don't think I don't
think it was demonic possession I think
it I never think it's I think it was
just I think was just run-of-the-mill
classic poltergeist case was RS PK
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
basically what you're talking about is
talking about a psychic temper-tantrum
that can manifest itself and make a
permissions and make you believe that
it's something that it isn't like a
ghost or a demon or you know can do that
now the second part of the case the guy
stabbing the other guy I don't think I
don't think the demon had anything to do
with that I think he maybe if this case
happened he may have been traumatized by
it and maybe he thought he was under the
influence of something like that but I
think it was more of a defense of others
case you know I think was pretty much
and and you know I think his his counsel
his lawyer made a big mistake by trying
to argue the case in that way yeah I
kind of feel like maybe the lawyer was
like yeah let's do that maybe I'll get
famous you know because I'm trying to do
this crazy I'll write a book and then
all write a book about it cuz it was so
wacky cuz I think he seemed to really
think that that defense was gonna work
but then he's got his diamond cuz the
judge was like nah man we're not doing
that don't you come in my courtroom
[ __ ] I was like what like I said
yeah how'd he just use the self defense
attorney it's like no nobody would ever
have heard of this case there could what
I'm saying is that could be something to
the first part of the case uh-oh baby
coos turn get it baby cookie payment I
well I got her Christmas presents and I
leave the you know I got it from chewy
and you know so the box is in here with
paper in it and she's like a home right
so I left it in here so she could play
in the box she comes in here when we're
trying to record and she's like playing
in the box so that's what that says so
but yeah I I think there may have been
something to the first part of the case
I don't think there's anything to the
second part of the case yeah I always
spent most of the time with these it's
like I feel like maybe there was a minor
poltergeist active
and then hey there's the other cat and
you know and then invaded by cats all
this kind of stuff gets added on to it
and embellished over the years and you
know like I said people's book royalties
are involved I want to make a movie
about it and you know what I mean so
it's kind of hard to get to the bottom
of this type of thing yeah all right so
she's getting kind of restless I guess
we wrap this show up or she starts
making even more noise so remember I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode 121
about a haunting episode and the devil
made me do it case remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe and all
your social media share with all your
friends and family if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar if you'd like to give a one-time
donation to our paypal account remember
to check out our last movie review which
was a double feature dead and buried and
deaf blind aka raw meat who were which
were gary sherman movies so check that
out also our last matinee which was
episode 9 that came in on sunday and
that will do it for episode 121 we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]